سخرت الطاقه النوويه للاستخدامات السلميه
والعسكريه في السابق لكن لماذا هذا
الاحتفاء بتقنيه الاندماج النووي الان
ولماذا تعتبر اختراق علميا
دعونا نتعرف على هذه الطاقه التي يعمل
العلماء في المستقبل ان يوفر كيلوغرام
منها يوميا ما يعادل 1000 ميجا واطن من
الطاقه الكهربائيه لوضع الامور في سياقها
فان انتاج مثل هذا الكم من الكهرباء
سيحتاج تقريبا الى نحو 800,000 كيلو جرام
من النفط اذا كيف ستعمل اليه الاندماج وما
الفرق بينها وبين الانشطار النووي المعمول
به حاليا في الانشطار النووي تستخدم عناصر
مشعه كاليورانيوم تنشاطر الى جزئين او
اكثر
وتنطلق النيوترونات التي تصدمه هي الاخرى
بذرات العنصر المشعه وتستمر هكذا في ما
يعرف بتفاعل طار النوويه عند الانشطار
تتولد الطاقه وهذا هو المبدا الذي قامت
عليه قنبته هيروشيما النوويه وتستخدم
مفاعلات نوويه حاليا ويبقى فيه خطر التسرب
الاشعاع قائما لاستخدامه النظائر المشعه
لكن الاندماج النوويه مختلف هو عباره عن
اصطدام ذرتي هيدروجين ببعضهم تحت ظروف
حراره وضغط كبيرين ليكوننا ذره اليوم
تماما كتفاعلات التي تجعل النجوما كالشمس
مشتعله لمعرفه كميه الحراره والضغط
المطلوبين يمكننا النظر الى القنبله
الهيدروجينيه التي طورت في الخمسينيات من
القرن الماضي هي قنبله نوويه تعمل باندماج
النووي لكن لتفعيل هذه العمليه نحن بحاجه
الى تفجير النويا انشطاري لتوفير الطاقه
اللازمه للانفجار النووي مندماجيه التفجير
النووي للانشطاري سيوفر كميه الاشعاع
اللازمه لتكوين ما يسمى بالبلازما
المشتعله وستسمح الظروف ببدء الاندماج
النووي للهيدروجين اذا تكونت ظروف تشبه
مركز الشمس هنا يكمن سر تقنيه الليزر
الجديده اذ وفرت الطاقه اللازمه للاندماج
النووي بدل توفيرها عبر انفجار النووي او
استخدام طاقه هائله اكبر من تلك التينتجها
الاندماج النووي المطلوبه
وستسمح تقنيه الاندماج السنيه هذه بتوفير
طاقه نوويه لا يخشى فيها من الاشعاع كما
هو معمول به حاليا في المفاعلات النوويه
التي تستخدم الانشطار نووي والموده المشعه
كيورانيوم